- Le groupe Constructif pourrait naître également,
au Sénat.
Est-ce que ça peut faire exploser le groupe
LR, ici ?
- Non, je ne le crois pas.
Vous savez, je le dis mais pas avec bonheur.
Vous savez, j'ai passé l'âge des petites
phrases et des arrières-pensées,
et des petits calculs de carrières
Pour un certain nombre de cas, franchement,
Ca ne m'inspire pas beaucoup d'indulgence,
mais s'il y en a qui sincèrement ; Considèrent
que ce que fait le Président de la République,
ce que fait la majorité est formidable,
C'est assez logique, mais qu'ils aillent au
bout de leur logique, qu'ils les rejoignent.
- Et quitter LR ?
- Encore une fois, je peux redire ce que je
disais :
Toute une série de personnes ont été investies,
soutenues et finalement élues grâce à l'étiquette
des Républicains, et le lendemain ils s'en vont.
Franchement, est-ce que l'on peut être épatés
sur le plan moral ?
Non, je ne suis pas épaté.
Moi, je pense qu'ils doivent partir, clairement.
- Entamer des procédures ?
- Je vous le dis, vraiment, très profondément :
Cela serait respectable et moral. Les deux.
Ils nous ont quittés, pour certains été
récompensés, puisqu'ils sont au gouvernement.
Mais je pense que ça serait plus moral et respectable
qu'ils en tirent toutes les conclusions.